ja gut morgen wir sind in wildbad essen
im kreis höxter im dreieck von nrw
hessen niedersachsen und hier hat der
winter krise wirklich zugeschlagen wir
sind jetzt hier an einer kreisstraße bei
eisen und deshalb muss bei uns und sie
hat es heute morgen richtig heftig
erwischt was ihnen passiert ja wie
gesagt ich war heute vor 60 arbeiter
gewesen
und da war wirklich richtig finde ich
hier tue mich nur und ich straße voll
mit schnee haben die kann gestreut gar
nichts und ja den autos wissen gerutscht
und wie nicht
auf dem grab einfach nur ja dann aber
wir dem polizei und den schiffen
angerufen zum auto weg bringen
die war hier ja polizei war der autohof
schirmbar da wir haben nicht geschafft
mit dem schwerpunkt zu kriegen dann
haben die mir ja gesagt die sollen noch
einmal mit den kran zu kommen zum
abholen und ja das war für mich wäre
wirklich super wie gesagt zum comeback
heute ist mein geburtstag am sieg das
futter bin ich gewonnen und war ich zum
arbeiter wie gesagt es war ein bisschen
pech und glück auch weil ganz ehrlich
wenn ich da sehen wie die aussieht dass
er nicht viel passiert wo die auto auf
ein grab und der es keine schaden auf
strasser kein schaden dürfe kein schaden
ist im auto und das ist mein glück aber
wir sehen hier verstehen hier wirklich
mitten im schnee das ist mittlerweile
fast ein meter würde ich sagen in den
letzten drei stunden hier
zusammengekommen
und herr mundie sie haben in dem moment
ist ihnen auch richtig die muffe
gegangen glaube ich sie haben vorhin
geschildert ja immer noch immer noch ich
habe wirklich
angst gehabt und ich war so erschrocken
ganz ehrlich gesagt ja und ich bin immer
noch wissen
ich finde ich eher die
kreispolizeibehörde höxter hat uns auch
gesagt sind hier in richtung paderborn
einige straßen gesperrt werden weil
bäume umgestürzt sind auch der
winterdienst wie überall kaum
hinterherkommt mit räumen
jetzt ist für sie die frage sie müssen
zur arbeit herr mundie warum ist ihr
wagen jetzt noch immer hier in dieser
misere und in diesem graben ja wie ich
vorhin gesagt die wollen da das auto
schleppen damen die nicht geschafft und
ihr denn von der firma zum schleppen
sagt dazu mir der roboter mit einer
dinge wie heißt den transrapid den kran
zum zum wegnehmen und der wollte heute
so ungefähr da gesagt um 9
ungefähr vorbeikomme und dann die auto
wegnehmen dann hätten sie sich ins
trockene und ins warme und alles gute
und hoffentlich können sie ihren
geburtstag noch irgendwie heute noch
nach feiern und das wendet sich alles
noch zum guten für sie vielen dank herr
mundie alles gute ja und wir müssen hier
weiter sehen wie wir uns auch selber aus
diesem schnee befreien hermoni hat
wirklich wirklich zu schaffen hier
entsprechend wieder loszukommen
und es sind ungefähr minus sechs grad in
bad driburg das ist also auch
tatsächlich etwas südlich von höchster
von paderborn und das ist eine der am
stärksten betroffenen gegenden wo auch
die nächsten stunden weiter schneefall
erwartet wird und damit gebe ich erst
mal zurück zu euch ins studio bzw
dort wo auch ihr seid jetzt mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bate schaue ich hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren